[Music]
I don't want to watch this video with
just me and Marsh because I feel like I
wanted a female's perspective do you
know who Barbie Ferreira is
no okay well she's awful she's awful
like I should know well she used to work
for vice she's a fat cow
um okay and this is their perspective
title of this video is Barbie Ferreira
and Gigi gorgeous I don't know who that
is I know who GG okay so they're perfect
so each of us knows half of this video
okay perfect on internet trolls and how
to behave so this is how you now I want
to see if you this is if she's giving
good advice
God I already hate this video okay
that's Gigi gorgeous is one of the OG
trans influences yeah yeah hey hey
that's right hold on I'm Barbie Ferreira
and I'm gonna teach you by the way I
know and by the way does she have pink
eye what's happening there she always
kind of looks like she has pink she
always looks a little sick here's the
thing with her her face is not bad but
it's an iceberg because it's really
widens out it's like a pyramid like you
know if you see Pittsburgh it's a
exactly exactly to behave
foreign
this is I can already tell she's someone
who is more confident than she deserves
to be like this person has that's always
been her bid that's always been her bed
yeah enforcement like I can already tell
like no there's not enough substance but
there's a whole lot of confidence coming
off this girl unearned just unearned
yeah this is this has always been her
Shake is like check me out it's like uh
I did and uh pass why
I tried yeah and I hated it pass place
where literally Anything Goes
trust me look at this what is this oh
what's the good look I don't want to see
a sea space unless I'm ordering a
[ __ ] cappuccino that's the only time
I will tolerate what like looking at a
face like this is this is this is
nothing to make my coffee this is what
everybody who owns an Etsy store looks
like yeah yes this is
a nice Brooklyn lesbian look like if
it's mad
did you say Patton Oswald transition
Virgie yeah there it is
that's right now now I'm gonna start
killing husbands oh no now I'm gonna
overdose husbands and remarry really
fast and everyone's gonna pretend like
that's normal makeup looks like if any
either of you dudes went as a chick for
Halloween that that's like how you would
do your makeup just sort of like [ __ ]
yeah you just throw it on because I
don't know what I'm doing I don't want
honestly I don't want to look like I
know how to do it that well you know she
even gonna wonder she looks like an
extra like an extra in a John Waters
film you know she looks like she found
her eyebrows
[Laughter]
oh my God hey can I get the ugly stupid
fat librarian look for Halloween thanks
it means that people get trolled and
harassed but others use it for
self-expression and creativity okay I'd
rather hang out with the people that are
trolling and what are you doing with
your tits
she wants everyone to know well she
should eyes the internet
navigating the world of social media can
be as hard as navigating real life no
no real life has [ __ ] real
consequences you could just leave
Twitter stupid
to get real life canceled for your
online opinion I mean I guess that's a
good point but I think the way she's
framing it is like the other way like oh
my God being picked on is so hard on the
internet
go meet like Barbie Ferreira is not
gonna get canceled you know no she
doesn't seem like she has any spicy
takes yeah the only thing she cancels
every three months is her curves
membership to the [ __ ] cam that's
about it with her you gorgeous we're
gonna speak about internet hate because
I feel like she has a lot to say about
that sure Gigi has come out three times
the first time she came out wait I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay get out three times
how do you do that because
is she going back in maybe hold on hear
me out gay
came out as a gay guy then a lesbian
then a Tran no trans trans would have to
be first you know I like attention too
okay well yeah
wow you know what maybe she really is a
woman
yeah does she have a birthday Mom
we're all going to Cabo this weekend
it's my 30th oh my God now she came out
as a gay man the second time she came
out as a trans woman and third time she
came out as a gay woman oh look at that
huh
so you went full circle then basically
so it cancels out the other things I
think wow that's really going the long
way around of just being a normal
relationship once you come out as trans
like that's the most coming out you're
gonna do like anything after that is
kind of like anticlimactic yeah we're
done here okay you're also a lesbian big
[ __ ] deal trance should be the last
one right that should be the grand
finale you know where you're really
committing
so I'm looking to learn from Gigi on how
to be vulnerable online oh my God look
at this woman's house or this whatever
it's so it's you know for you for
YouTube purposes it's a woman
look at this they all like it's already
like she's don't tell me about hate if
you live in a [ __ ] place that looks
like this um
you're you're good you're not struggling
with hate on like oh just look at turn
around look at your money that's what
that's how you deal with your online
hate you look at your bank account wow
yeah exactly like better who you you Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan probably gets more hate
than anybody in the world because he's
the biggest podcast in the world right
do you think when he's walking around
his mansion He gives a flying [ __ ] what
people are saying on the internet like I
don't get that like I you're right maybe
you get a lot of hate but you know you
know what you also get a lot of money
you know and it's it's weird and I don't
know why she's dressed like she's
running numbers for Jimmy Two Times what
is that is that a velor sweatsuit I
think they've been canceled like these
people are
spouting the messages of the mainstream
no I know exactly Trans Pro all the [ __ ]
so it's like what how what do you know
about a difficult life they don't other
than your dad hating you or doing all
those things but like okay that's you
assuming he's alive you don't like Sunny
the balls gravano no I don't like Sunny
the balls gravano over here
[Laughter]
okay listen I know boy listen and this
is why and now you talk about you talk
about this Chrissy a lot but like
what she's doing is blackface for women
and it's bad black face it's like does
she think women just sit around on
humongous teddy bears and sprinkled
covered like this is also something that
Dylan Mulvaney do it's not only woman
face but it's like girl face yeah like
they're doing girl black face because
it's like grown women don't have
gigantic stuffed animals in their
[ __ ] room yeah you know what they're
doing they're sitting on the couch in
their sweatpants eating chips like the
rest of us
they're not sitting there on like oh my
God I can't do it okay well can't wait
to get home and just sit on my huge bear
and be a lesbian
unless you that Bear's tummy is full of
with an arsenal of vibrators like no
grown woman is gonna have a bear like
that I don't know if it doesn't but I
tell you what that bear probably is full
of [ __ ] come it's just [ __ ] crusty
ass where can I come there yeah that
bear wasn't that color initially on the
internet what was that experience like
honestly I can't even remember my life
without the internet it's been like
that's sad number one one of the saddest
things I've ever heard ever gorgeous is
I think only in their 20s still no way
that's not a 20 year old maybe 30.
Virgie how old is Gigi gorgeous
Virgie do me a favor look up Gigi
gorgeous's delicious [ __ ] see what comes
up thank you yes please just see oh no
we're doing this to me God damn it don't
send me the cocket that's for you that's
that's a tip for being a good producer
it's been like almost eight years now
and after I was done with my transition
I was kind of I was like how do I get
more attention how do I keep
transitioning more
30 years old and if you're wondering
blue glitter I was not wondering I was
right okay
that's like you know like it's like and
then I know it's my engagement was going
down and then I needed to do something
else it's like even the talking it's
it's me try harder being a girl like
five years
when I'm mocking white women exactly you
know what I mean like oh yeah trying to
make fun of me they sound exactly like
this like you sound like a gay dude
making fun of a chick
I have all of this footage that can
probably help some people I've literally
heard my Carlo make fun of women this
way that's what this sounds like yeah
bike Rules by the way I love them people
out there because you have so many
questions you don't know who to talk to
some people have nobody to talk to every
single situation was a could it be maybe
you have nobody to talk to because you
[ __ ] suck
right wait [ __ ] suck or [ __ ] ends up
the answer is yes very like you you
really didn't enunciate that yes and or
less talking more sucking
that's the name of that's the name of
Chrissy's next album
[Laughter]
getting easier for you to be more
personal in opening up about things
coming out as trans was definitely one
of the hardest things I've ever had to
do you know what the hardest thing to do
is have to listen to you come on by the
way look at this by the way Chrissy this
[ __ ] Nails your point it was one of
the hardest things I have to do verified
with three million views it must have
been so difficult so hard wow everything
in the in the culture is supporting you
wow I had to come out and the only thing
that's the only thing that supports me
is Google Amazon Coca-Cola Walmart
sponsors all my free makeup and [ __ ] you
know what Gigi you want to be brave Come
Go full circle come back around come out
as a straight white man now that would
be amazing come out as a trucker yeah
that would come out as a Canadian
trucker
and then guess what the next thumbnail
and the next title the next [ __ ]
clickbaity title is going to be on my
bank account Frozen yeah out as a mega
Republican that's you want to know
difficult that's dangerous yeah they're
out there [ __ ] getting sponsored by
[ __ ] they're getting sponsored by
Coca-Cola and MasterCard and we have to
[ __ ] show food buckets don't [ __ ]
tell me it's an even playing field these
dudes are getting sponsored by Tampax
and they don't even have vagina oh my
God that's true
like what are we gonna put this tampon
in your butthole yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's to soak up all the blood
um
I know but it's true it's gross but it's
true okay sign up for my subscribe ass
blood welcome to the ROTC Election Day
special well we best trans people oh my
God ass blood oh stick it up your ass
and then I don't know I've seen tampon
commercial and you ride a horse or some
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know oh no no I
think it's the other way around
[Laughter]
and their defense Beyonce used to do
like shampoo commercials so yeah I know
and she used to sell sunblock but
[ __ ] for why
um
listen [ __ ] I it would be funny the
next the only next logical thing is I'm
not joking 10 years from now it's like
hi I'm Gigi gorgeous and I'm coming out
as a map now I'm a map I'm a minor
attracted person that's gonna be the
next one and you're like yeah we know
yeah we know we already knew you came
out as all the other things I mean
statistically speaking yeah you're like
an 89 chance
want to be female I have felt for a very
long time now that I was a girl trapped
inside of a boy's body all right so let
me let me add this straight
so you were [ __ ] lying to us
[Music]
yeah so when you came out the first time
you [ __ ] you were you were lying by
Omission you didn't want to tell us the
whole story how many times you're going
to tell us half a [ __ ] story you you
actually might be a woman you know Royce
might be right you might be a white
woman because it's taken you 12 years to
tell one story but it's like you said
you know what I mean Jesus Christ the
way it was a tree transfers know what no
it was gay first then trans then lesbian
enough already yeah all right you've had
look you've had all the attention Okay
we're out of attention now
all the things it's [ __ ] that
attention is backwarded now the only
thing left is to run for office yes
that's it and probably [ __ ] win if
she runs like but I'm running against
Caitlyn Jenner
he said I could stay at his house I
thought that was super cool of him I
mean I'm bringing my hammer
foreign
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] weird keep her away from
Daryl Hammond I miss him on on the ip2
RV we gotta get Andy Dick back you're
[ __ ] weird no seriously because any
dick already killed Phil Hartman the
next one on this list I really believe
is Daryl Hammond and I'm really worried
for him uh-oh
but you know along the way you know you
find out different things about yourself
and I think it becomes more exciting
because it's like I'm literally being
the most authentic me that I can be and
you wake up with less everything about
you is like and physically like fake
like so how can you be authentic if
everything's fake and I mean so you're
authentic but you were wrong three times
too
is my point yeah
how do I trust you now how do we we've
already with this relationship that we
should have built on trust it's already
shattered now you've told me three
different stories GG all right I need
you to be stupid you really are without
the help of many doctors and surgeries
and hormones then like I don't know no I
mean it's not who you're supposed to be
I mean listen I get it sometimes God
makes a lemon but Jesus [ __ ] Christ
not everything's a fixer-upper you know
you know what I need a bottle of Jameson
and a pack of smokes you see simple GG
simple life all right you'll be much
happier that way
okay we haven't even got to the troll
part guys we haven't even got to the
troll part I'm wearing your heart and
less weight on your shoulders in your
own words what is an Internet troll
somebody who just of course I know him
it's it's me thank you a picture of the
three of us
to me an Internet troll is
um somebody who hides under Twitter and
eats billy goats and if you're thinking
of a literal troll me a troll is anybody
who has less followers yeah exactly
anyone who doesn't have a verified check
mark they're questioning my girl nobody
rolls and lurks it's so funny that she's
just trying to sound so much like a girl
and Chrissy has to try to sound like a
guy to sound like the female version of
this so I have to do my stuttering
generation uh
uh control
fine like a [ __ ] leech on my kicks
cause I'm too liberal
the trolls told the people in San Diego
how liberal life was
so take care of me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the night doctor was trolling me because
he wouldn't give me more hormones yeah
exactly so I had to buy him illegally
online from that girl star's name starts
with a K that I'm not gonna say yes
okay you don't want any bathtub hormones
and honestly I feel like I've like built
such a thick skin like anyone can say
anything
about the hormones and all the work
you've had done it's the scar tissue
from the work
ah no that's just layers of makeup but
can I say I love I love this just out of
touch thing of like how do you deal with
trolls online when you have three
million followers and everybody loves
you is how hard is it for you to once in
a while see somebody say hey shut up
and when you're verified on everything
especially Twitter like you can choose
to only see other verified messages oh
no they love it notifications so it's
like you could I think you can more
easily block that out when you're
verified but they love it I think they
love it it's so hard being on a platform
like I can just snap my fingers like
Thanos and I can just disappear anyone
who criticizes me even miles like I hate
the Trolls but I need them to maintain
my Victim status so I sort of like as a
victim it's hard sometimes to get called
out for legitimately bad behavior that I
engage in in any icon of honest and
honest criticism it's just an attack
it's like the family guy thing where
it's like sure ma'am you can't smoke in
here I'm trans I'm sorry do whatever you
want all the time yeah
let's see what the world is we go yep
because I've heard it a thousand million
times
so I took to social media oh good to see
if anyone had any personal questions
that they've been it changes I do have a
few of them but I can't ask them on
YouTube yeah and hopefully Gigi will do
a little q a with me if you can answer
them I think this girl is giving me like
she's giving me Lena Dunham Vibes I
think oh yeah like Revel in her
mediocrity and like unflattering poses
unflattering clothes she's like flabby
and like doesn't seem concerned with it
no yeah Lena Dunham is actually a great
way to describe her she she's like the
she's like the new version right it's
Brooklyn dumpy Chic yeah
if you look like a dumpster like you
spent three thousand dollars to look
like you're homeless yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's these people are the worst
see what the kids got to say
how does it feel to know that you're a
role model to so many people
depression bot right there look at all
these trolls oh mirror you yeah yeah oh
god
um feels good it's a lot of pressure
role model kind of like I thought it was
terrible model
what is I thought you were just we just
we just spent [ __ ] two minutes
talking about terrible everything is
and then we're pivoting actually it's
really great that three million
followers and everyone give me money
it's insane oh my God not only you hear
about your beautiful too oh God these
people count that word a little bit
sometimes because I'm not trying to like
know everything or like pretend that I
know things that I don't I think that
that's where you get into like sticky
situations with like politics you don't
pretend to know things that you don't
like how it yeah no well never mind
don't do it Virgie you're breaking down
your your brain is breaking he's having
a logic Paradox virgie's the Westworld
robot in a fly just landed on his cheek
and now he's just like a reality doesn't
look like anything to me exactly
no that is clearly a penis I see it
and then they pull me and I have to
deactivate me I'm one of the robots that
goes back into the into the hole
underground I'm quoting Shakespeare and
[ __ ] they're like it's called it's
called new breast world but yeah I've
seen it haha
or no breast world oh either way yeah oh
my God like pretend that I know things
that I don't you got a real run on you I
think that that's where you get into
like sticky situations with like
politics and all that nasty stuff so
yeah it's the same kind of thing it's
like politics yeah politics Dwayne
Astron have to have a dilator to [ __ ]
make sure your [ __ ] hole doesn't
close you're right politics it's really
sticky it's a really sticky situation a
role model but I know you are in a way
yeah because by just living my life and
just like not
all right immerse doesn't like when
women speak their truth yeah it sounds
like you don't like anybody living their
authentic lives that's right you know
what I'm with Chrissy here live in our
best life I don't live the lives your
parents pressured you to live okay
girl
they wanted what was best for you you're
an idiot I mean
it's a little wordy for a t-shirt but I
don't hate it
being tied down by my insecurities
that's in itself being a role model
because so many people just like it's
instilled yeah I think about this sorry
the fact that Gigi doesn't want to get
involved in politics makes me think she
might be a republican because she makes
a ton of money she probably wants to
keep it and the the reason she's going
oh politics people don't say that unless
they actually believe something that is
the opposite of their fan base
just like my porn star friends that stay
away from politics it's because the
default like porn star politics is
Democrat and they're Republican which is
why they stay away from it because they
don't want to lose customers and the way
that Gigi said that makes me think that
you can figure out what you can figure
out how an only fans girl votes by what
her [ __ ] what her percentage says on
her [ __ ] bio on Twitter top five
percent only fans that's a republican
that's a good point and if it wasn't
what it is now if they're like top 60
only fans okay Democrat but I think
that's a little weird because I I think
it's like you know porn stars is the
only thing where your politics literally
doesn't matter like I'll [ __ ] you
think I when I'm jerking off someone I
go that better not be a liberal that
better not be a liberal you know what
surprise I like I like your series of
dildo videos but then I found out that
you voted for pardon
and I'm closing my account I just can't
good counts and stuff I'm told that it
has made a difference that like like
people that have mentioned where they
how they vote it's actually like Turned
I mean look I'm a big I've always been a
big believer in if you're in business
like the whole Michael Jordan always
said like you know they would say why
don't you you know support this Democrat
running those because Republicans buy my
shoes too so I do understand that
mentality of like don't get involved in
politics if you're running a business
right I mean you you nailed you know
they did that too Chris Pratt Chris
Pratt doesn't want to [ __ ] talk about
politics he just wants to [ __ ] go to
church and raise his family and make
movies and they keep going and in the
absence of him supporting Lego then he
must then he must be a Republican
and they they do they do that to you
they smear you Bruce Willis I mean they
literally made him [ __ ] so took a
whole thing I think he just became
[ __ ] maybe you know what maybe he's
living his authentic life
that's what he always was just [ __ ]
he's always getting [ __ ] he just
has no strength to do it he's like hey
look my kids are grown I just want to be
a [ __ ] now all right look he's earned
it Grandpa's earned Grandpa why was it
being a [ __ ] it could be a [ __ ] what
do you want us to do parade him around
like bite and embarrass the family no if
he wants to sit in a [ __ ] comfy chair
let him yeah more mashed potatoes
that's in itself being a role model
because so many people just like it's
instilled in you especially as like
young women to hate yourself like you're
supposed to hate yourself ma'am you
don't have to hate yourself I hate you
plenty you don't even please do not
waste time doing it
oh every single day yeah and people
always have comments and that's a whole
thing that you have to work on on
yourself confidence is key because I
love these people because they want to
be make their videos and talk about
whatever they want to talk about and say
I really want to say and I want to Shin
a man and but the moment you say
anything back it's like why are you
attacking me you just made a 10 minute
video saying white men are trash like
that's why I'm attacking you yeah and
also like it's so boring to say
confidence is key let tell me what in
your life makes you feel confident like
where are you getting all this
Confidence from if you supposedly have
so many trolls which I don't buy I
definitely don't buy I I I'm 100 sure
that the average Christie Meyer fan is
the troll is way worse than anything
these people get because I've seen them
and they're very mean to you
they want to kill you which seems really
odd it's like a lot of work mine are fun
huh yeah you're dumb your fans are
[ __ ] insane merch Jesus Christ you're
trolls I wouldn't call them fans well
well they listen every day they do they
do keep that engagement up that's true
okay what's your go-to response to a guy
who slides in the Diaz oh a guy that
slides in the DMS I'm a lesbian now okay
[ __ ] I still have it
that's what Chrissy replied to me when I
asked her to come on the show
probably not even a response because
none of the guys I always like look
through my requests but never accept but
look at her look at her look at her like
prepubescent belly that she has Barbie
forever what's going on there Barbie you
look up you like a potato salad is she
sitting on a bean bag chair only so that
she looks thinner by comparison
she looks like they stuffed the entire
cast of Requiem for a Dream into one
human skin okay that's fair he needs
shapes here she needs good posture she
needs flattering clothes it's again it's
this dumpy Brooklyn Chic thing it's
really bad
septic I'm scared of like what would
happen will you marry me can I find you
out for sure yeah let me just hop on
that plane through the Middle East yeah
hey you know what you should go to the
Middle East let's see if you have any
trolls there I will personally pay for
that I recommend like oh no like Iran or
like Syria
hi how come nobody ever gets mad at all
these countries all these Middle Eastern
countries are not accepting trans people
where do all these trolls get so many
rocks from
why do these shows have me tied up and
why do these girls let me tied up in a
soccer stadium I'm gonna have you
canceled
oh now the trolls are gonna throw me off
of a roof what's that about I'm
reporting you
that's Alabama really they're literally
trying to light me on fire it's asking
the Taliban to speak to their
for their manager can I speak to your
manager that should be really poorly
here
laughs
what I learned from DG gorgeous is being
your authentic self on the internet I
literally I literally learned nothing
about trolling all I heard this this
little thing about how to deal with
trolls was
life is really easy for us and we don't
have a lot of trolls
any negative messages how did you learn
how it's about to have some how did you
learn how to be yourself from somebody
who had like five versions of himself
I feel like that's very it's the last
person I would want to like oh
Jesus Christ see this person you started
to not like yourself you changed this
[ __ ] something else this [ __ ] has more
gimmicks than Chris Jericho it's
confusing she has more versions than
[ __ ] Skyrim okay I I was gonna say
she has more forms than the average
Pokemon there you go all of them work
great job everybody good job we all tied
it together evolution
[Laughter]
this is why we're winning elections
folks
oh [ __ ] trans people and Pokemon that's
such a perfect comparison because they
do start out very cute and small and
then their Mega Evolution is something
looking big and [ __ ] like ugly and
scary and you're like that looks nothing
like what it started as yeah then they
look like the shop teacher in Canada
which is big fake tits and a [ __ ] wig
they start all cute and cuddly breathes
fire now and if you trade them to your
friend over a Link cable they evolve
into a statistic
also they start off cute and cuddly and
eventually they've all evolved into a
terrifying looking foil covered monster
that's also an invasive species okay so
that's very specific but okay hey